[Music]
of course I love Star Trek I did that's
actually one of the things that I think
I get recognized most for actually is I
did an appearance in Star Trek 6 my mom
had cast that and I got to I was about
20 years old and I got to be in a scene
with Captain Sulu cool George Takei it
was not a captain in this TV show he's
no no nobody's gonna move one of the
movies in the movie yeah he's the
captain of the Excelsior and that was
probably yeah that was that was a big
deal I mean that was one of the scarier
days of my life
you are a thank you you you're not just
a kind of interested in Star Trek
am I correct you really like Star Trek
in fact you collect memorabilia well
there let's see there a buddy of mine
knows I'm a huge Trekkie and knows I
love the show I love William Shatner I
just went and saw his one-man show how
was it it was hilarious he was great and
a man it was it was funny and it was
adorable and I explained actually even
why he acts the way he acts the way he
does that you know Spa why must you
what's the reason reason he was doing a
show I think in like his 30s and he was
working with a woman who spoke no
English I guess she was Korean and she
spoke no English so in order for him to
get her to do things he would speak in
this way
that explains working with that one
woman that's one time but then to take
that as an acting Styles insane I know
according to the play that's craziest
piece of memorabilia that you have the
most impressive Star Trek memorabilia
that you have I guess the most a buddy
of mine did get me the the Captain Kirk
chair from you have the Captain
Kirk chair the 1963 show yeah I mean
it's it's a wonderful you know you can
push the buttons and the lights go on
and and I love it you have this you have
the D Captain Kirk oh that's fantastic
yeah yeah I know it's great it's great
and have you revealed this to anybody
else I mean if you did you recently I've
gotten into like the tweeting thing yes
and I mean it is it is a chair that my
character in breaking in does sit in
yeah he does sits in the Captain Kirk
chair because it's just it has an air of
mystery about it you know it's a
powerful chair I like it's an iconic
chair it's an iconic chair
but so I tweeted the photo of the chair
and then I got a lot of nice tweets back
from people actually I got a tweet back
from a guy I don't know if you guys have
the photo this is a fan said I've got
one too yeah this is a fan who also has
one and I don't know why he dresses his
Captain Kirk this is it this is a real
fan who's just in his what in his living
room or something look I don't know
where it is I haven't been to his house
but that's the we both know you've been
my best friend so yeah that guy he sent
me the photo and I immediately felt the
the photo behind him actually also has
it's him in the chair with Nichelle
Nichols and and other cast members are
shown in the original shows very
impressed with this when you are at your
house and you're just hanging you're
chilling and you sit in the captain's
chair do you ever dress in a Star Trek
uniform
it's a good question
I will yeah I can't really confirm or
deny that I was we've got our answer
we have our answer like for Halloween
once I did good okay so pretty much
pretty much every night okay
[Applause]
breaking in this is a really fun show
are you having a good time making it you
guys have a great cast it is a great
cast and Megan Mullaly from willing
grace is involved in the show now and
she is yeah she's great hilarious
absolutely wonderful out of her mind
comedy genius so we're certainly
enjoying having her being a part of it
but it is a kind of show that does speak
to it's like a geek time show I mean we
had a tauntaun in the last episode on us
on a Star Trek reference that is a Star
Wars reference is that right I'm not
sure yeah of course it's yeah difference
of course you can't say Tom Tom and then
like come on man you were just nerd
bullied gonna be beaten on the way home
taunt on Star Trek
Taunton was in Battlestar Galactica with
diver James Olmos
I don't know what's happening anymore
I think it's Thursday the flood of
disinformation I think I'm coming a
bright line